It seems that everyone brought a celebration
Thank you for your concern
I think Mr. Yokota likes this kind of thing.
I called this
[music]
Finger bones.
I made it, the
sky is cool You can eat this
How do you like it? Does it look like a
frenzied nobleman?
From me, this is
another elongated box,
you know this
is an anteater, isn't it?
I think it's
too far from the south gate g It's
easy to say that there are sharp teeth here.
It's different from the one-eyed giant, oh,
cool, oh, oh, this is a statue
, the hole in the middle is not a hollow for the eyeball, it's the nostril hole
It looks like the cloth is
hanging.The second place
was a
head.Bones were in the end of the
soul.It's fun to think about animals from now on.